Guten Morgen.
Heute brutal früh unterwegs ...
... auf unserer Expedition
in eine unbekannte Schweiz.
Also!
Ui, was ist das? Unterhosen? Nein!
Ach nein!
Jesses, Stulpen, Fussballstulpen!
Und ein Autoschlüssel.
Es kann nichts Besseres passieren,
als morgens um noch nicht mal
4.30 Uhr hier zu stehen
und zu wissen, dass man
vermutlich in ein Sportlager muss.
Das Navi ist programmiert:
57 Min. von hier, Richtung Westen.
Das genaue Ziel: unbekannt.
Ich befürchte wirklich, dass ich
in ein Fussballcamp gehen muss.
Dort wird man sehen,
dass ich weder Ausdauer
noch irgendeine Ahnung
von Fussball habe.
Das Wort Morgengrauen bekommt heute
eine ganz neue Bedeutung.
Es geht nicht
nach Bern ins Stade de Suisse,
sondern rechts weg
nach Niederbipp im Kanton Bern.
Dort sitzt schon einer auf ...
Muss ich zu dem hin?
Hoi.
* Lachen *
Das ist
die grosse Gemüseindustrie hier.
Schau dir das an!
Ab ins Treibhaus!
Morgen.
Ich glaube, hier werde ich erwartet.
Und es ist kein Fussballtrainer.
Nein.
- Mona Vetsch.
Beat Bösiger. Freut mich, Mona.
- Dürfen wir uns duzen? Beat.
Du musst mir ...
Du bist Gemüsegrossbauer?
Genau.
Aber warum hat man mir
diese Fussballstulpen gegeben?
Das wirst du
im Verlauf des Tages noch sehen.
Oh, Überraschung.
- Die wirst du brauchen können.
Okay.
- Ich sage dir noch nicht wofür.
Aber du wirst sie brauchen.
Ich bin erleichtert, dass
ich nicht Fussball spielen muss.
Aber vielleicht wird es ja schlimmer
als jeder Fussballmatch.
Wir schneiden heute Morgen Salat.
Man muss ihn taufrisch ernten,
und das geschieht eben frühmorgens.
Mona Vetsch drei Tage im Gemüse.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
(Bösiger in Niederbipp ist einer der
grössten Gemüsebauern der Schweiz.)
(Er hat 12 ha Gewächshäuser
und Folientunnel,
eine eigene Verpackungsanlage
und 150 ha Gemüse im Freiland.)
(Hier bin ich eingeteilt.)
(Eisbergsalat schneiden - das kann
ja nicht so schwierig sein, oder?)
Man schneidet den Salat.
So sieht die ganze Pflanze aus.
Dann schneidet man etwas mehr weg.
Dann werden diese Blätter entfernt.
Bis er so aussieht.
Gut, tipptopp. Also!
Vielen Dank.
Wie viel nimmt man weg?
Ist das gut so?
Gut. Jetzt musst du aufpassen.
Dieses Blatt ist angeschnitten,
das muss weg.
Und das hier darf nicht sein.
Okay. Wird das sonst braun?
- Ja, das wird braun.
Jetzt müsste man
noch ein, zwei Blätter wegnehmen,
aber dann haben wir das Problem,
dass der Salat zu weiss ist.
Der ist schon ...
- Ich habe ihn kaputtgemacht.
Nein, du kannst ihn doch
nicht wegschmeissen.
Der ist nutzlos.
- Aber ich könnte ihn doch essen.
Ja, aber es gibt noch genug andere.
Oh Gott, ich muss also
weiter unten schneiden.
Jawohl.
- Okay. Also so?
Den ersten Salat
gleich kaputt gemacht - grossartig.
Und wenn du schneidest,
solltest du die Blätter
nicht auf die Salate fallen lassen,
sondern dort,
wo bereits geerntet wurde.
Du kannst bei ihm zuschauen.
Wie heisst er?
Adelino.
- Adelino.
Der Chef hat gesagt, du seist ganz
gut, ich solle bei dir zuschauen.
Also dann.
Zack, zack, zack!
- Zack, zack!
Und er ist der Profi. Das ist Pinto.
Er ist ein super Packer.
Gut, dann wünsche ich euch
einen schönen Morgen.
Danke. Ciao, Beat, bis später.
So ...
(Handarbeit, alles.)
(Nur der Traktor
ist satellitengesteuert
und zieht das Förderband
Stück für Stück weiter.)
(Die einzige andere Frau beim Salat-
schneiden ist Eva aus Portugal.)
Seit wann bist du hier?
Ich bin dieses Wochenende gekommen.
Das ist meine erste Woche.
Oh, wow!
Und warum bist du hierher gekommen?
Ich habe zwei Kinder,
und das ist eine Chance,
die ich in Portugal nicht habe.
Sind deine Kinder auch hier?
Sie sind in Portugal.
Du musstest sie
in Portugal zurücklassen -
wie ist das für dich?
Es ist sehr hart,
aber ich muss es machen.
Yes.
(Andere kommen schon seit Jahren,
um hier zu arbeiten.)
(Die Arbeitsbedingungen seien gut,
Startlohn 3'235 Fr. brutto.)
(Im Vergleich zu einem Lohn in
ihrer Heimat ist es das Sechsfache.)
* Stöhnen *
Ja, aber ...
* Jemand lacht. *
Lachst du mich aus? Er lacht!
Kannst du mir helfen? Es ist kaputt.
Ich habe es kaputtgemacht.
Nicht kaputt?
- Nicht kaputt.
Aber ein bisschen kaputt ist es.
Es ist eingeklemmt.
* Stöhnen *
Jetzt muss ich noch mal.
Ein Neues?
- Nein, nein.
Sicher? Es ist nicht so ganz gut.
Ah, super.
(Um 11.45 Uhr mit Mittagspause.)
(Ich setze mich
zu Jose und Cristina.)
(Sie sind gemeinsam
aus Portugal gekommen.)
(Er ist eigentlich Informatiker
und sie ist Medizinlaborantin.)
Guten Appetit.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Danke.
Wir haben uns entschieden,
in die Schweiz zu kommen,
weil ihre Eltern hier sind.
Your parents?
Ja, meine Mutter
arbeitet auch hier bei Bösigers.
Okay.
Wir haben uns entschieden,
unser Leben zu ändern.
Die Schweiz
ist ein guter Ort zum Leben.
Und zum Arbeiten.
- Yes.
Wie sieht euer Leben hier aus?
Ich arbeite, ich gehe nach Hause,
wir bereiten das Abendessen zu,
und dann gehen wir schlafen.
Denn wir müssen
um 5 Uhr morgens aufstehen.
Wir arbeiten 10 Std. pro Tag.
Am Samstagmorgen auch.
Das Wochenende ist kurz.
Yeah.
Hallo.
(180 Personen arbeiten hier
in der Haupterntezeit
von März bis November.)
(Ich hatte mir doch
noch nie überlegt,
wer das Gemüse erntet,
das ich im Laden einkaufe.)
Du musst zu den Zucchetti, nicht?
Das ist der Zucchetti-Chef, Misel.
- Zucchetti-Chef Miguel.
Miguel, hallo.
- Misel. - Misel!
Gut.
Fährst du mit ihnen?
- Ja.
(Und hier auf dem Feld
erfahre ich endlich,
wofür die Fussballstulpen sind.)
Das ist nicht für die Beine?
- Nein, für die Arme.
Für die Arme? Mann!
Habt ihr das gehört?
Des Rätsels Lösung.
Ich brauche diese
nicht für den Fussball,
sondern für die Zucchettiernte.
(Als Stachelschutz.)
(Zucchetti verursachen beim Ernten
fiese kleine Schnitte,
die sich entzünden könnten.)
* Tiefes Tröten *
Der Startschuss.
Jetzt beginnt die Zucchettiernte.
Alle liegen am Boden. Warum?
Wenn sie sehr gross werden,
dann bekommen sie diese Form.
Aber das ist schlecht.
Und ...
Das ist gut, das ist auch gut.
Das ist schlecht.
Das hier. Die Form.
Diese Form ist nicht gut?
- Die ist nicht gut.
Warum?
Ich weiss nicht.
Der Chef bestimmt das.
Na gut. Nur gerade Formen sind gut.
Ja.
Das Minimum ist so.
- Minimum?
Das ist das Minimum.
Kürzer geht nicht.
(Rui arbeitet wie alle anderen 10
Std. pro Tag, sechs Tage die Woche.)
(Wir bekommen Besuch
auf dem Zucchettifeld.)
Bösiger Senior.
Grüezi.
Ah, das ist jemand für mich.
- Ja, genau.
Mona.
- Peter.
Du bist also Peter? Wenn ich
dich einfach so duzen darf ...
Hilfst du uns, Zucchetti zu ernten?
Bist du schon etwas müde?
Es ist doch anstrengend.
Ja, für den Rücken.
Aber früher habt ihr
das ja sicher nicht so gemacht,
als du noch Bauer warst.
Nein. Ich bin auf einem ganz
normalen Betrieb aufgewachsen.
Eben, kein Gemüse
und nicht so gross.
Nein.
Das kam erst, als wir ...
... als wir heirateten.
Als ihr geheiratet habt. Wieso?
Hast du eine reiche Frau geheiratet?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Aber eine, die gut arbeiten konnte.
Dann braucht es keine ...
- Aha!
(Peter und seine Frau
arbeiten trotz Pensionierung
noch voll im Betrieb mit.)
(Er im Büro, sie im Hofladen.)
Tomaten, Gurken
und all diese Sachen.
Und das hier ist Beats Wohnhaus.
Er wohnt gleich nebenan?
- Ja.
Wirklich?
Also das sieht nicht
nach Work-Life-Balance aus.
Beat ist wirklich
mit seiner Arbeit verbunden.
Da gibt es keine Distanz.
- Das stimmt.
Er ist so aufgewachsen wie ich.
Er musste immer mithelfen
und bekam Freude daran.
So ist man einfach
mit dem Ganzen verwurzelt.
(Als Peter mit dem Gemüseanbau
begann, war alles noch ganz anders.)
Wir hatten zwei Pferde und Pflüge.
Die Kartoffeln haben wir noch
mit dem Pflug angehäufelt.
Es ist Wahnsinn, wenn man bedenkt,
dass das noch gar nicht
so lange her ist.
So viel hat sich verändert.
1993 haben wir
so richtig angefangen.
In den letzten 25 Jahren
haben wir das hier aufgebaut.
Wahnsinn.
Läuft das noch unter Bauernbetrieb?
Ja, das läuft noch alles
unter Landwirtschaft.
(Und im Vergleich
zur europäischen Konkurrenz
seien sie ein kleiner Betrieb.)
... sind die Nachkommen?
Hier werden wir erwartet.
Ja, das ist meine Frau.
Hallo, Mona, ich bin Therese.
- Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
(Das ist sie also,
Peters fleissige Frau.)
(Sie zeigt mir meine Unterkunft
für die nächsten drei Tage.)
Das ist ein Einzelzimmer.
Und das sind Doppelzimmer für Paare.
Und du bist hier.
Das ist ja wie im Hotel.
Ich werde sicher gut schlafen.
Dann gute Nacht.
- Einen schönen Abend.
Vielen Dank.
Schönen Abend. Ciao, vielen Dank.
(Nach dem Tag auf dem Feld
bin ich geschafft.)
(Zum Glück
muss ich nicht selbst kochen.)
(Silvia aus Moldawien
und ihr rumänischer Mann Sorin
laden mich spontan zum Essen ein.)
Du hast studiert in Moldawien?
Ja, ich war
an der Landwirtschaftsuniversität.
Aha, du hast Agronomie studiert?
Ich bin Agronomin.
Mein Beruf ist Agronomin,
aber ... jetzt.
Jetzt ...
- Jetzt packe ich Tomaten ein.
Ich staune ein bisschen.
Warum ist das so? Darf ich fragen?
Warum? Wegen ... Das ist nicht
mein Land, nicht meine Sprache.
Es ist schwierig, hier zu arbeiten.
Als Agronom.
Aber in unserem Land
gibt es nur wenig Geld.
Deshalb sind wir hergekommen.
Wovon träumst du?
Wie soll dein Leben in fünf
oder zehn Jahren aussehen?
* Seufzen *
Ich will Kinder haben und ...
Aber ...
Sowieso gehe ich
in mein Land zurück.
In dein Land - Rumänien?
-Ja.
Aber im Moment ist es gut hier.
Ja, aber du möchtest dann ...
- Ja.
... in fünf Jahren oder so
wieder in Rumänien leben?
Ja, denn wir wollen Kinder haben.
Wofür leben wir? Für die Kinder.
Nicht alle denken so, aber ...
Für mich ist es besser so.
(Vor dem Essen gibt es noch
einen Gruss aus der Heimat.)
(Gebrannt von Sorins Mutter.)
Gott, Maria und Josef!
Oh la la! Ist gut, ist gut!
Nur zum Probieren.
Weisst du,
ich bin eine Frau und sehr klein.
Ich kann nicht viel Schnaps trinken,
sonst ...
Wie stösst man in Rumänien an?
Wie macht man es?
Tuica.
- Tuica?
Ja.
Zum Wohl!
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ah!
- Gut? - Ist gut.
Ein Geschenk.
Danke schön.
- Bitte.
* Gespräche, Lachen *
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich habe geschlafen
wie ein von rumänischem
Zwetschenwasser betäubtes Engelchen.
Tipptopp.
Mit meinen zwei stummen Kumpanen
ist es richtig gemütlich.
(6.30 Uhr, Besammlung.)
(Chef Beat Bösiger sagt,
was und wie viel geerntet wird.)
(Auch Beats Sohn Philipp ist dabei.)
(Beat wünscht sich, dass er
einst den Betrieb übernehmen wird.)
(Ich gehe nicht mit aufs Feld,
sondern ins Gewächshaus
zu den Gurken.)
* Musik aus dem Radio *
Jetzt, Achtung!
Wir ernten jeden Tag, denn im Ge-
wächshaus wachsen sie sehr schnell.
Die muss man jeden Tag schneiden?
- Richtig.
Wir haben genaue Gewichtsvorgaben.
Die Gurken müssen
400-500 g schwer sein.
Wir schneiden sie ab 420 g, damit
wir eine Gewichtsreserve haben.
Sie sollten im Laden 400 g haben,
also müssen sie morgen immer noch
das geforderte Gewicht aufweisen.
Wie findest du raus, welche gut ist?
Ist diese 400 g, siehst du das?
Ich denke,
die hat das Gewicht knapp.
Knapp?
Zur Kontrolle
haben wir eine Waage dabei.
Ich gebe dir das Messer.
Es ist extra ein kurzes ohne Spitze.
So verletzen wir die Pflanze nicht.
Ich würde sagen, diese hier kannst
du abschneiden und kontrollieren.
Hat sie das Gewicht?
Nein. Sieh an!
- Die ist zu klein.
Was machen wir mit dieser Gurke?
Die ist zu klein,
die legen wir zur Seite.
Die darf nicht verkauft werden.
Wenn der Kontrolleur bei
der Warenannahme diese Gurke nimmt,
auf die Waage legt und merkt,
dass sie zu leicht ist,
dann könnte er
die ganze Lieferung zurückschicken.
Ihr müsstet sie zurücknehmen?
Wir müssten alles
noch mal kontrollieren, abwägen,
und dann könnten wir
die Ware wieder bringen.
Diese hier sollte das Gewicht haben.
Genau, super! 444 g.
Diese hier
ist auch nicht vermarktungsfähig.
Diese ist zu krumm.
Die Vorschrift besagt,
dass sie gerade sein müssen.
Eine leichte Krümmung
dürfen sie haben,
aber diese
ist nicht vermarktungsfähig.
Nicht vermarktungsfähig - aha!
Es ist nicht einsichtig, warum die
eine gut ist und die andere nicht.
Das ist ja das Absurde.
Die Qualität ist dieselbe,
sie hat den gleichen Nährgehalt,
aber sie ist krumm.
Das ist ja das Absurde.
Aber woher kommt das?
Das hat sich
im Lauf der Jahre entwickelt.
Die Sorten sind besser geworden,
die Qualität ist besser geworden.
Und so hat man die Auswahl
zwischen geraden und krummen Gurken.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin auch so.
Wenn ich zwischen einem Apfel
wählen kann, der perfekt ist,
und einem, der eine Delle
oder einen braunen Fleck hat,
dann nehme ich den schöneren.
Das ist menschlich.
Hm, die ist zu klein.
- Nein, die ist nicht zu klein.
Machen wir den Test.
Ich bin gespannt.
446 g.
- Super.
Ich stelle dich gleich ein.
Du wirst gleich
als erste Gurkenschneiderin gewählt.
So.
Armin,
wir haben dir Gurken gebracht.
Fein.
Wehe, du sagst etwas
gegen unsere Gurken.
Wehe, ich finde eine,
die nicht gut ist.
(Armin ist der Chef
der Gewächshäuser.)
Ich würde sagen, diese ist kleiner,
die ist zu leicht.
Meinst du? Nein.
Oh, doch.
2 g zu leicht.
Aussortieren! Das geht nicht.
Manuel ist Spezialist für das.
Du siehst jeder Gurke an,
wie schwer sie ist?
Diese ist 430 g.
Auf das Gramm genau!
Warum kannst du das?
Ich kontrolliere alles.
(Erfahrung.)
(Vor sieben Jahren
als Erntehelfer angefangen,
hat sich Manuel zum Vorarbeiter
im Gewächshaus hochgearbeitet.)
(Er verpasst mir eine
Schnellbleiche bei den Tomaten.)
(Die Pflanzen werden immer wieder
hochgebunden und werden 9 m lang.)
(60 kg kann man
pro Quadratmeter ernten.)
Aufpassen, dass die Schnur
nicht die Traube blockiert.
Immer schauen,
dass der Kopf nicht kaputtgeht.
Wir schneiden alle roten.
Wir schneiden hier.
Und nie die weissen schneiden.
Ich schneide und du schaust,
dass ich es richtig mache.
Okay.
- Gut? Sicher?
Also.
Wie läuft es hier
bei Mona und Manuel?
* Mona lacht. *
Tipptopp.
Und weisst du jetzt schon
Bescheid über Tomaten?
Etwas, das du mir
noch erklären musst, ist:
Wie kann es sein,
dass sieben Pflanzen ...
... sieben verschiedene Pflanzen ...
Du sagtest 9 m, nicht?
Ja, 8 oder 9 m.
... 8-9 m aus
so einem kleinen Ding rauskommen?
Was ist dieses Zeugs hier?
Dieses "Zeugs", wie du es nennst,
ist nichts anderes als Steinwolle.
Und die wird getränkt?
- Genau, getränkte Steinwolle.
Die Pflanze hat nie Erde, sie wächst
in diesem Steinwollewürfel.
Aber es gibt sicher Leute,
die sagen: "Steinwolle, keine Erde -
ist das überhaupt noch natürlich,
was ihr da macht?"
Oder sind das halbe Roboterpflanzen?
Nein, das sind
keine Roboterpflanzen.
Die Pflanze nimmt die Nährstoffe
genau gleich auf,
egal ob sie in der Erde
oder in der Steinwolle wächst.
Für dich gibt es keinen Unterschied?
Denn Bio ...
Doch, es gibt
einen grossen Unterschied.
Gegen Abend sollte eine Tomate
weniger Wasser bekommen.
Die Pflanze nimmt immer Wasser auf,
und wenn sie abends viel Wasser hat,
gibt es eine wässrige Tomate.
Das ist für den Geschmack nicht gut.
Und das kann ich hier
viel genauer steuern.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
(Hier wird nichts
dem Zufall überlassen.)
(Jeder Tropfen genau dosiert,
die Temperatur im Gewächshaus
konstant 3 °C kühler als draussen.)
(Vor dem Abpacken wird das Gemüse
noch mal ganz genau kontrolliert.)
(Was noch nicht passt,
wird passend gemacht.)
(Der Preis des Gemüses
wird jeden Tag neu ausgehandelt.)
(Dafür ist Hans Affolter zuständig.)
Morgen.
Neutrale Folie.
Joaquim
bringt am Nachmittag für Coop.
450.
(Er ist der Trader, der Verkäufer.
Sein Job:
das Gemüse nicht zu billig anbieten,
aber auch nicht zu teuer,
sonst bleibt er darauf sitzen.)
Bei mir kannst du sicher sein,
dass du Qualität bekommst.
Sonst würdest du nicht
bei mir kaufen.
Ich kenne dich inzwischen.
Ciao.
(In der Unterkunft der Erntehelfer,
19 Uhr abends.)
(Silvia kocht und ihr Mann Sorin
widmet sich seinem Hobby.)
(Zu Hause in Rumänien
hat er ein grosses Aquarium,
aber hier gibt es zu wenig Platz.)
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
(Oben bei den Portugiesen
ist es weniger ruhig.)
(Es ist Fussball-WM,
und Portugal spielt gegen Spanien.)
Ronaldo!
(Es endet 3:3 -
meine portugiesischen Kollegen
gehen zufrieden ins Bett.)
(Vor 30 Jahren war das noch
ein kleiner Bauernbetrieb,
heute führt Beat Bösiger,
der neuerdings auch im Grossrat
des Kantons Bern sitzt,
ein Gemüseimperium,
das immer mehr Organisation
verlangt.)
Stimmt es eigentlich, dass es
schwieriger wird, Leute zu finden,
die auf dem Feld arbeiten wollen?
Ja, das hat sich
dieses Jahr abgezeichnet.
Zum ersten Mal haben wir etwas Mühe,
genug Leute zu finden.
In den letzten Jahren
gab es immer genug,
wir hatten Berge von Bewerbungen.
Jetzt ist es
zum ersten Mal nicht so.
Ich nehme an ...
Ich nehme an, die Wirtschaft
läuft wieder besser in Portugal
oder auch in Rumänien, Polen.
So haben die Leute
weniger Interesse daran,
als Gastarbeiter
in die Schweiz zu kommen.
Wenn ihr die Leute aus dem Ausland
nicht habt,
dann bringt ihr das Gemüse
nicht in die Läden, richtig?
Dann ist es nicht möglich.
In der Schweiz
haben wir nicht genug Leute,
die diese Arbeit zu diesen
Bedingungen machen wollen.
Dann müssen wir einfach
unseren Anbau zurückfahren,
entsprechend den Arbeitskräften -
das ist der limitierende Faktor.
Aber es geht immer noch.
Wir haben noch genügend Bewerbungen,
dank Mund-zu-Mund-Propaganda
in ihrer Verwandtschaft.
Es ist noch nicht schlimm.
Es ist irgendwie lustig:
Du bist im Grossen Rat für die SVP.
Deine Partei
ist ja nicht dafür bekannt,
gerne Ausländer
in die Schweiz zu holen.
Aber du brauchst sie auf deinem Hof.
Wie gehst du damit um?
Mit dieser Situation
habe ich keine Konflikte.
Wir haben sehr viele Asylbewerber
bei uns angestellt.
Ich möchte das in der Schweiz
vorhandene Potenzial ausschöpfen.
Ich möchte nicht noch mehr Leute
reinholen - im Gegenteil.
Aber dort stellt uns oft
das administrative Verfahren,
das sehr kompliziert ist,
vor Herausforderungen.
Bei den Asylbewerbern?
- Richtig.
Würdest du gerne mehr anstellen?
- Ja, gerne.
Wieso kannst du nicht?
Der administrative Aufwand
ist riesig.
Wir merkten,
dass die Leute arbeiten möchten.
Es sind auch sehr fleissige Leute.
Wir verstehen uns gut mit ihnen.
Aber wir haben es langsam aufgegeben
mit dieser ...
... Bürokratie?
- Ja. Das ist wirklich schlimm.
(Mit Peter muss ich
Gemüse für den Hofladen packen.)
(Der Hofladen befindet sich im
ehemaligen Kuhstall von Bösigers.)
(Das ist das Reich von Therese.)
Gut!
Das sind die, die ihr nicht an
den Grossverteiler verkaufen könnt?
Genau.
Aber bei euch haben die Leute
kein Problem damit?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Gut. Ja.
Gab es in deinem Leben
eigentlich auch mal Ferien?
Ja, ja.
- Sicher, kennst du das?
Doch, doch.
Eine Woche gehe ich gerne.
Jetzt haben sie aber
14 Tage gebucht.
Das ist nichts für mich.
Du musst zwei Wochen in die Ferien
und das bereitet dir Bauchschmerzen?
Das bereitet mir
etwas Bauchschmerzen.
Aber es geht alles vorbei.
Im Leben geht immer alles vorbei.
(Für Therese
sind Ferien ein Müssen.)
(Alle anderen
freuen sich aufs Wochenende.)
(Und bald ist es auch hier so weit.)
(Dann stehen alle Maschinen
etwas mehr als 24 Std. still.)
(Die letzten Nachbestellungen
müssen raus in die Läden.)
(Auch meine Schlummermutter Silvia
ist im Endspurt.)
So, almost finished?
Fast fertig, oder?
Ja, fast fertig. Noch ein bisschen.
Noch ein bisschen.
- Noch 16 Min.
Aber ab morgen Ferien, oder?
Zurück nach Rumänien?
Ja, zurück nach Rumänien
für eine Woche.
Und dann wieder zurückkommen ...
... und weiterarbeiten.
Was machst du
in Rumänien als Erstes?
Ich muss mich
mit einer Frau treffen,
um ein Papier für das Haus
zu unterschreiben.
Haus?
Ja.
Du und Sorin
kauft zusammen ein Haus? - Ja.
In Rumänien?
- Ja.
Dann kann ich aber gratulieren,
oder?
Ja. Danke.
Dafür habt ihr hier
so lange gearbeitet.
Ja. Drei Zimmer im ersten Stock.
Und oben hat es Platz für Kinder.
Ein Haus für deine Familie,
die du hoffentlich bald hast.
Ja.
(Ich nehme Abschied von Silvia
und allen anderen bei Bösigers.)
(Drei Tage im Gemüse reichen dafür,
dass ich in Zukunft
etwas anders vor dem Regal mit den
Zucchetti und Tomaten stehen werde.)
(Und vielleicht
bin ich ja nicht ganz die Einzige.)